THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
WE BEGAN WITH BIG BREAKING NEWS.
IT'S OFFICIAL.
KANYE WEST TURNING HOLLYWOOD AND
THE LIBERAL MUSIC WORLD UPSIDE
DOWN, PLEDGING HIS FULL THROATED
SUPPORT AND LOVE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE WRAPPER TWEETING:
"YOU DON'T HAVE TO AGREE WITH
TRUMP BUT THE MOB CAN'T MAKE ME
NOT LOVE HIM.
WE ARE BOTH DRAGON ENERGY.
HE IS MY BROTHER.
I LOVE EVERYONE.
I DON'T AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
ANYONE DOES.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES US
INDIVIDUALS.
AND WE HAVE THE RIGHT
TO INDEPENDENT THOUGHT."
HE ALSO TWEETED A SELFIE.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, SUPPORT IS
APPRECIATED BY THE PRESIDENT.
TRUMP RESPONDING TO THE RAPPER
ON TWITTER, WRITING:
"THANK YOU KANYE, VERY COOL!"
SARAH SANDERS WAS ASKED ABOUT
HER.
>> KANYE WEST HAS BEEN IN THE
NEWS FOR SUPPORTING THE
PRESIDENT AND EXPRESSING HIS
ADMIRATION.
I AM CURIOUS WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT HAS REACHED OUT TO
KANYE WEST AND WHETHER HE WOULD
BE WILLING TO MEET WITH HIM AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> I DON'T KNOW OF ANY
CONVERSATIONS THEY'VE HAD OVER
THE LAST WEEK OR SO.
I WILL KEEP YOU POSTED IF THAT
CHANGES.
SORRY, I KNOW THEY MET DURING
THE TRANSITION.
THAT'S THE ONLY MEETING I AM
AWARE OF THAT'S TAKEN PLACE OR
CONVERSATION.
BEFORE EVERYBODY HAS A MELTDOWN.
>> Kimberly: AS WE SAID
YESTERDAY, AT THE TRUMP TOWER
TRANSITION MEETING.
THE INTERNET FREAKING OUT OVER
THIS.
COMMENTS LIKE I NEVER NEEDED A
PHOTO OF KANYE WITH A MAGA HAT
ON AND STILL DON'T.
DOES EVERYONE BELIEVE THIS IS
LEGIT OR IS IT THE ULTIMATE
TROLLING GOING ON?
>> Greg: THIS IS ACTUALLY A
BIGGER DEAL THAN JUST WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON TWITTER.
IT'S A BIG DEAL BECAUSE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS YOU ARE
COLLAPSING THE WORLD OF
CONVENTIONAL ASSUMPTIONS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE SUPPOSED TO STAY IN
THEIR BOX.
IF YOU GET OUT OF YOUR BOX,
THERE'S GENERALLY AN ONLINE MOB
THAT WILL COME AFTER YOU FOR
YOUR POLITICAL BEATS OR ANY
BELIEFS.
WHAT HE'S DOING RIGHT NOW, WHICH
IS KIND OF INSPIRATIONAL, AND I
ACTUALLY DO THINK IT'S A FAIRLY
BIG DEAL.
BIGGER THAN THE ROSEANNE THING.
HE IS 18 MILLION FOLLOWERS AND
THEY WATCH E!
AND BRAVO.
IT'S A DIFFERENT WORLD HE IS
REACHING OUT TO YOU AND IT'S
KIND OF HEROIC WHEN I KNOW
PERSONALLY MUSICIANS AND ACTORS
ARE JUST REGULAR PEOPLE WHO ARE
PUNISHED FOR OFFERING A COUNTER
NARRATIVE, ANY KIND OF COUNTER
NARRATIVE.
HE'S BASICALLY STANDING UP AND
SING I WILL TAKE THE SLINGS AND
ARROWS.
I'M OKAY WITH IT.
I AM BIG ENOUGH.
RETURNING TO THE CANDACE OWENS
THING.
HE WAS SUPPORTING HER NOT FOR
IDEAS BUT FOR HER GUTS, AND HE
WAS STILL TARGETED, WHICH SHOWS
THERE IS A MOM OUT THERE THAT
WANTS TO SILENCE YOU IF YOU
LEAVE YOUR BOX.
WHAT HE'S DOING AND WHAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE DOING, LIBERALS,
DAVE RUBENS AND SAM HARRISS AND
JOE ROGANS.
THEY ARE LEAVING THEIR BOXES.
THEY ARE ENDEARING PEOPLE TO
COME WITH THEM.
PEOPLE WHO ARE THE INTELLECTUAL
CONFORMITY.
I DON'T KNOW.
HE IS CELEBRATING IT.
THE TWEETS ARE A CELEBRATION I
THINK.
>> Kimberly: FANTASTIC.
DANA, WELCOME BACK.
>> Dana: THANKS.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO "THE FIVE"
IN THREE DAYS WHEN I HAVEN'T
BEEN HERE?
I HAVE GOT A PERSONAL FEELING
ABOUT KANYE WEST AND WHAT HE
SAID ABOUT GEORGE W. BUSH DURING
KATRINA WAS OUTRAGEOUS.
MAYBE HE WOULDN'T SAY THAT AGAIN
TODAY BUT IT'S A TERRIBLE THING
TO DO TO SOMEBODY.
WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN REALLY
BRAVE WOULD HAVE BEEN REALLY
BRAVE WHAT HAVE BEEN GOING AFTER
THE REAL CULPRIT, AS IN THE
LOCAL, STATE GOVERNMENT THEY DID
NOT HELP THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
PEOPLE OF NEW ORLEANS.
I BELIEVE THAT THERE.
I ALSO THINK, IN ADDITION TO ALL
THE THINGS GREG SAID, I THINK
IT'S A GREAT WAY TO GET
PUBLICITY BEFORE YOUR ALBUM
COMES OUT.
>> Kimberly: 100%.
"THE FIVE" I'M NOT SAYING THAT
IT'S NOT REAL.
I THINK IT CAN BE BOTH.
>> Kimberly: THE TIMING COULD
BE AUSPICIOUS.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK HE
NEEDS PUBLICITY FOR HIS ALBUMS.
I THINK THEY SELL PRETTY WELL ON
HIS OWN.
>> Kimberly: JESSE, WELCOME
BACK.
GREAT JOB YESTERDAY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
WE SHOWED THE FOOTAGE YESTERDAY
THAT HE WAS A TRUMP TOWER, THE
TRANSITION.
HE WAS WELCOMING A MEETING WITH
THE PRESIDENT, AS HE WAS WITH
CANDIDATE TRUMP.
WHAT IS THIS, AN EXTENSION OF
THAT OR IS THERE SOMETHING ELSE
GOING ON OR COMBINATION?
>> I'M NOT AS CYNICAL AS DANIEL.
I AM HOPEFUL FOR KANYE.
I THINK HE HAS MATURED SINCE HE
SAID WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
GEORGE W. BUSH AND KATRINA.
I THINK HE WOULD AGREE THAT THE
NEW LOVING KANYE WOULD LOOK BACK
ON THAT MAYBE NOT AGREE.
HE ALSO SAID HE LOVES HILLARY.
I THINK HE IS TRYING TO LEAP
FORWARD WITH LOVE.
SAYING IF I LIKE THIS PERSON IT
DOESN'T MEAN I HATE THEIR
OPPONENT.
I CAN'T SAY IT ANY BETTER THAN
GREG JUST SAID.
I THINK YOU CAN'T UNDERESTIMATE
WITH MY NONCULTURALLY AND
POLITICALLY.
HE IS SHATTERING THE PARADIGM OF
US AGAINST THEM, THE TRIBES, ALL
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
WE HATE EACH OTHER.
IT'S A NEW PHENOMENON BECAUSE
PEOPLE HAVE NOT REALLY EXPRESS
THEMSELVES LIKE THIS.
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN SOMEONE AT
THIS LEVEL OF CELEBRITY SHOCK
AND AWE THE PUBLIC TO SUCH AN
EXTENT WHERE PEOPLE ARE SAYING
WHAT'S HAPPENING?
YOU MUST BE MENTALLY ILL.
IT BLOWS PEOPLE'S MINDS.
THEY ACTUALLY THINK HE NEEDS TO
SEE A DOCTOR.
REMEMBER, THAT'S WHAT THEY SET
ABOUT TRUMP BECAUSE HE HAS SO
MUCH DRAGON BLOOD OR WHATEVER.
SOUNDS LIKE CHARLIE SHEEN.
>> Kimberly: DRAGON ENERGY.
>> Jesse: PEOPLE COME ALONG
AND BREAK THE MOLD.
CONNIE IS ONE OF THEM.
DONALD TRUMP IS ONE OF THEM.
BREAKS CONVENTIONAL WISDOM.
LET'S ALSO REMEMBER BLACK
AMERICANS, NOT ALL OF THEM,
BLACK AMERICANS LIKED
POLITICIAN.
YOU'VE SEEN PICTURES.
HE WAS IN THE BOXING GAME.
HE WAS OUT AT NIGHT TIME TAKING
LOTS OF PICTURES WITH OTHER
CELEBRITIES.
PEOPLE ADMIRED HIS
ENTREPRENEURSHIP, HIS FLASHING
IS, HIS STYLE AND WEALTH.
AND THE WOMEN HE HUNG AROUND
WITH.
THINGS CHANGED WHEN HE BECAME
POLITICAL BUT HE WAS ADMIRED FOR
NOT BY A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES.
NOW THE FACT THAT HE'S COME OUT
AND HE HAS SAID SOME THINGS THAT
HAVE ANGERED PEOPLE OF THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN YOU CAN'T
CHANGE AS A PERSON.
DOESN'T MEAN YOU HAVE TO LEAVE
THAT PERSON.
I THINK TRUMP HAS MATURED JUST
AS MUCH AS KANYE.
>> Kimberly: YOU MEAN THE
WONDERFUL WIVES HE'S HAD.
>> Jesse: YEAH.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
>> Jesse: NEW YORK SOCIETY FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS.
>> Kimberly: JUAN, HAVE YOU
RECOVERED FROM JESSE?
>> Juan: I AM TRYING MY BEST.
I THINK IT'S A SUPERFICIAL
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I THINK
KANYE WEST IS THE SAME GUY, AS
DANA SAID, WAS INSULTING
REPUBLICANS A MINUTE AGO IN A
WAY I THOUGHT WAS UNFAIR.
NOW HE COMES BACK AND I GUESS
IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE A MARKET
FOR PEOPLE WHO SAY WELL, BUT NOW
HE LIKES TRUMP, SO WE WILL RALLY
TO KANYE.
EVEN HIS WIFE SAID HEY, YOU
DON'T AGREE WITH ALL THE
POLITICS.
KANYE WOULD SAY THAT'S TRUE BUT
IT DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE I ALSO
LIKE HILLARY.
HE HAS THE DRAGON ENERGY OR
WHENEVER.
IT'S SO SILLY AT A TIME WHEN IN
AMERICA WE'VE GOT LIKE, YOU
KNOW, BLACK WOMEN ON ALL GOLF
COURSE IN PENNSYLVANIA WITH THE
POLICE CALLED TO GET THEM OFF.
OR THE STARBUCKS SITUATION.
OR THE YOUNG MAN WHO WAS SHOT
AND HIS GRANDMOTHER'S BACKYARD
IN SACRAMENTO.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON REAL
ISSUES IMPACTING RICE IN THE
COUNTRY, WE ARE FOCUSING ON
KANYE WEST.
IT'S NOT ABOUT ANYTHING OF
SUBSTANCE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN WITH A RECORD
COMING OUT, HE LIKES
DONALD TRUMP.
I GUESS ALL OF THE DONALD TRUMP
FOLKS WILL GO BY MATT KANYE WEST
RECORDS.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE KIND OF
RESPONSE KANYE EXPECTS, TO
DISMISS HIS BELIEFS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
HE STEPPED OUT OF THE BOX, SOME
OF THE GOING TO ACCUSE YOU OF
OPPORTUNISM.
YOU ARE PROBABLY SOME KIND OF
MARKETER.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
HE KNOWS THAT.
>> Juan: I THINK YOUR ANALYSIS
IS WAY OFF.
IT'S NOT ABOUT STEPPING OUT OF A
BOX.
WHAT I AM SAYING IF THIS GUY WAS
LIKE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
THOMAS.
IF HE WAS SOMEONE -- LET ME
FINISH.
IF HE WAS MAKING A SUBSTANTIAL
ARGUMENT ABOUT HOW DONALD TRUMP
IS THE BENEFICIAL FORCE IN
AMERICAN LIFE IN TERMS OF BLACK
PEOPLE IN THAT BLACK PEOPLE
HAVEN'T ALL BEEN BRAINWASHED --
>> IF YOU HAVE A QUARREL WITH
WHAT HE SAID BECAUSE YOU DON'T
LIKE IT.
>> Juan: THE ARGUMENT IS THAT
HE HAS NO ARGUMENT.
>> Kimberly: HE IS SOMEONE WHO
IS AN ENTREPRENEUR AND SOMEONE
HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY.
>> Juan: THAT'S FINE.
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH NOW
SUDDENLY HE'S A FAN OF
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Kimberly: HE IS ENTITLED TO
HIS OPINION.
WHAT DOES DIFFERENCE DOESN'T
MAKE?
>> Juan: SURE.
>> Jesse: MORE ABOUT WITH THE
CANDACE OWENS THING, CELEBRATING
PEOPLE FOR BEING INDEPENDENT
THINKERS.
YOU EXPECT SOMEONE LIKE CANDACE
OWENS, YOUNG BLACK PEOPLE IN
AMERICA, TO THINK THE WAY A LOT
OF OTHER YOUNG BLACK FEMALES IN
AMERICA THINK ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S USUALLY ABOUT 90% ONE
WAY.
HE IS CELEBRATING HER BRAVERY,
INDEPENDENCE OF THOUGHT,
STEPPING OUT OF THE BOX AND
STEPPING UP TO THE MOB WHO COMES
AFTER HER FOR SAYING SOMETHING
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE IN HER
GROUP DON'T BELIEVE IN.
IT'S MORE ABOUT GROUPTHINK AND
BREAKING THROUGH IT AND
CELEBRATING PEOPLE'S
INDIVIDUALITY.
>> Juan: THIS IS WHAT GREGORY
WAS SAYING.
WHEN I AM SAYING IT'S NOT ABOUT
GROUPTHINK.
IF CANDACE OWENS OR KANYE WANT
TO MAKE AN ARGUMENT, I'M GLAD TO
HEAR IT BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY
ARE SAYING.
IT IS LIKE JOHN LEGEND TODAY
TWEETED OUT SOMETHING LIKE STOP
CALLING THE COPS ON BLACK
PEOPLE.
EVERYBODY SAYS IT'S A RACIST
COMMENT BECAUSE BLACKS HAVE A
HIGHER CRIME RATE, ET CETERA.
STOP AND THINK ABOUT IT.
IF YOU AND I ARE OUT ON THE
STREET AND SOME COP HITS ME IN
THE HEAD, YOU'RE GOING TO SAY
WHY ARE YOU HATING JUAN?
>> Jesse: I UNDERSTAND THE
ARGUMENT.
>> Kimberly: THEY KNOW YOU.
THEY KNOW YOU, JUAN.
LETS PEOPLE HAVE THEIR OWN
OPINION AND THEIR VIEWPOINTS.
IT WOULD MAKE THIS COUNTRY
DIVERSE AND IT WAS SHOULDN'T